[Music]
one idea which I think makes sense to a
lot of people is that the brain is
constantly forming hypotheses about
what's going on in the outside world but
in order to take this idea of how the
brain performs hypotheses and make that
concrete really requires bringing
together computational scientists
together with neuroscientists
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the eye is kind of like a camera in that
it uses many of the same optical
principles but it's very unlike a camera
in that the eye was designed for a very
different purpose so for example a
camera is designed to produce beautiful
photographs that you can look at later
but the eye is not trying to do that and
evolve for a much different purpose and
that is to acquire information
dynamically from the environment so
there's a vast amount of data that's
streamed out of the eye to the brain
most of this data is largely forgotten
the minute you look away all that
essentially disappears and so the brain
needs to figure out on the fly how to
assimilate this information which parts
to throw away which parts to add to your
model of the world and what it's trying
to do with this data is not produce some
kind of a beautiful rendition of the
scene or store it there's no hard disk
drive in your brain kind of trying to
store this information it needs to try
to build a model of the world to guide
actions that's what it's trying to do
not produce pretty pictures
we can actually learn a lot about our
own visual system by looking at other
visual systems throughout the animal
kingdom one example of the jumping
spider
which has eight eyes to explore its
visual world it has two very
high-resolution eyes in the front that
it uses to do pattern recognition it has
eyes on the sides of its head which have
low resolution but it uses to detect
things in the environment to look at the
box jellyfish has 24 eyes that it uses
to navigate through its aquatic
environment and it's almost as though
when nature is trying to build these
different visual system it's just saying
let's throw some sensors on here and
just gather lots of data about that
world and brains have a way of figuring
this out it's just taking all this data
streaming and figuring out how to
assimilate it into a model that can be
used to guide action so I think the
important lesson here is that there are
some foundational principles that that
we can really learn about in studying
visual systems that are much older than
our own that are much simpler than our
own before we even sort of ask questions
about how to humans and other mammals
see probably one of the largest
misconceptions that we have about visual
perception is that we're just
experiencing the image on the back of
our eye but that's definitely not the
case because this data that comes in
it's it's noisy it's incomplete it's
unstable it's non uniformly sampled and
so forth so everything we experiencing
about the world largely has to be
generated internally by the brain it's
the brain having to take its
expectations it's models about what it
thinks the world is like combining that
with data in order to generate these
percept that we experience
so in some sense perception is really a
process of controlled hallucination it's
a story that we're making up it's
largely correct hallucination it works
most of the time
and and this is how we're going about
building our our perception of world
so in order to understand the process of
image formation and sampling the eye we
first have to look at the structure of
the eye itself so I'm going to do here
is draw a picture of the orbit of the
eye with the lens in front and the
retina behind the retina is basically a
very thin hemisphere of tissue which
contains the rods and cones which are
the photo receptive elements which
actually detect light at the back of the
eye I'm just going to draw them as
little sticks so when we look at an
object in the world I'll just draw the
object as a arrow out here the object
then the image is projected onto the
back of the eye the shape of the object
is then sensed by the photoreceptors but
the brain does not actually get to see
the output of the photoreceptors itself
it does not see it does not get to see
the rod retinal image rather there's met
there's a lot of neural circuitry within
the retina and the output of all that
reginal circuitry and computations is
fed to a set of cells called retinal
ganglion cells each of these retinal
ganglion cells has a wire called an axon
which comes out of it and the collection
of all these wires together then exit
the back of the eye and it's this bundle
of fibers coming out of the retinal
ganglion cells which is a result of a
highly processed image within the retina
which is actually fed to the brain the
retinal ganglion cells do not sample the
image uniformly as in a camera rather
they're packed very densely in the
center and much more sparsely obviously
moved towards the periphery so the
region of visual space for which you
have high acuity is actually very small
this means that in order to see the
world in high detail we must constantly
be moving our eyes for example when
looking at this woman's face one moves
your eyes about the scene to specific
locations like the eyes the nose and the
mouth what's very interesting is that
even though these movements are
purposeful they're not just random
scanning movements you're largely
unaware of them
when you read a book your eyes are also
constantly in motion of course your eyes
have to move from one word to the next
across the text through the page and so
you maybe hold your eyes briefly on one
part of the text and then you move to
the next word in the next word and so
forth and it kind of may be jerky manner
through the text even when we think
we're holding our eyes still such as
when you're fixating an individual
letter on the page of text the eye is
still in motion these motions consist of
two things one is a slow drift motion
across the retina and also corrective
microseconds which are small eye
movements which try to keep the object
in the center of gaze we think these
small eye movements are actually helpful
to vision and that they help to build a
higher acuity representation of the
object within the cortex as you walk
through the world your eyes are also
constantly in motion you're looking at
the ground plane you're trying to figure
out where to place your feet where to go
you're looking at maybe objects of
interest and so forth but your eyes are
constantly in motion and interestingly
your body is also in motion of course
and your head is bobbing up and down and
so there's machinery neural machinery
and muscles that are trying to keep your
eyes stabilized essentially trying to
stabilize the retinal image as you're
going through all of this motion as you
move through the world
[Music]
now let's think about how this visual
information is represented in the brain
the information from the retina is
essentially streamed here into the
visual cortex but in the back of the
brain this is the front of the brain and
the eyes sort of lied right under here
so what's interesting about this
arrangement when the information comes
in the cortex is that it's essentially
split in two you have two brains inside
of you a left hemisphere or left brain
and a right hemisphere or right brain
the left brain is getting projections or
information from the left half of each
of the retina which in turn get
information from the right visual field
so information from the right half of
visual space is going into your left
brain the right brain gets information
or projections from the right half of
each retina which are in turn getting
information from the left visual field
so the left visual field is essentially
getting projected into your right brain
so it's kind of astonishing about this
arrangement is its entire visual field
is split in two with one half going to
one brain and the other half going to
the other brain but note that as we
mentioned before because of the highly
non uniform sampling of the retinal
ganglion cells in the retina these
images that are projected into the
visual cortex are highly distorted
images of the world highly expanded here
in the center of vision and highly
compressed as you go into the periphery
it's amazing that our brain can produce
such a stable and geometrically correct
percept in the world even though the
image data coming into it is so highly
unstable and highly distorted this may
just look like a movie in the back of
the brain but of course much more is
going on within the area v1 the primary
visual cortex there's computations that
are happening there which try to extract
features of the visual scene and then
they send on this information the next
visual area so called area v2 v2 does
some processing on that sends it on to
the next visual area and eventually this
information percolates to these much
higher level areas so there's basically
a hierarchy of information processing
where low levels low level areas in this
hierarchy are processing information
about the image about image property
and neurons and higher-level areas are
trying to extract more abstract
properties the world about objects and
motion and so forth happening one of the
exciting ideas that's really emerging
right now is this idea of trying to
develop computational theories based on
the framework of Bayesian inference more
than 200 years ago the Reverend Thomas
Bayes formulated the foundations of
probabilistic inference what we today
call Bayes rule what basis rule
essentially tells us is how to update
our belief in a certain hypothesis after
we've seen some data so we can write
that out as follows we write the
probability of a certain hypothesis
given some data D the hypothesis age in
perception is basically our belief about
a state of the world whether we think a
certain object of a certain reflectance
as surface a certain surface is out
there in the world the data is basically
the sensory information which are
measurements about light about sound
intensity and so forth that we get from
the sensors about what's going on in the
world but the data does not directly
tell us what's actually happening in the
world this is an inference so the
problem are our brain has to solve is
figure out is to figure out what's the
most probable explanation for what's
going on in the world what basis rule is
tells us is how to calculate these
probabilities and what it says is you
have to combine two different things one
is your model for how the data would
have been generated given a certain
state of the world so given that you
think there's a certain object out there
in the world of some color or
reflectance these are the activities you
would expect to see on your sensory
receptors and the second thing is your
prior beliefs about the state of the
world some explanations are more
probable than others and this comes from
your vast experience with the world or
it may be something that you're just
innately born with
these two terms are also divided by
another term called the probability of
the data or the evidence usually this is
just plays the role of a normalization
constant so we can ignore it because
what we're trying to judge is the
relative probability of different
hypotheses given the data what people in
computational neuroscience are trying to
do is to understand how these kinds of
computations are implemented in the
neural circuitry of the cortex in this
example the 3d scene and the shadows
suggest that the square in the middle of
the front face of the cube is orange
while the middle top square is brown if
we mask the picture so that the context
information is lost then we see that
they are exactly the same color so we
can understand this percept in terms of
the framework of Bayesian inference let
us consider two different hypotheses
that the brain might consider for the
scene hypothesis one is that we're
looking at a patch of orange that's
viewed in the shadow or low-light
condition and hypothesis 2 is the patch
is actually Brown and viewed in the
light so what does this term tell us
about these 2 different hypotheses well
both are actually equally consistent
with the measurements these are the
pixel intensities arriving at your
betcha retina and both of these
different explanations are equally
probable because an orange and shadow or
brown in the light would give rise to
the same intensity intensities arriving
at your eye so this term by itself does
not really adjudicate between these two
different hypotheses they're both
equally likely in both highly probable
explanations for for the data but now
let's consider the prior when looking at
this scene we have a three-dimensional
context which suggests that that this
frontal face of the cube is immersed in
a shadow and so if we go with the idea
that there's a shadow there the only way
that that patch could be in the light is
if there is a specific light source just
shining on that patch alone
where else in the scene we judge that
situation to be highly improbable
and therefore we this this idea of the
generic lighting assumption that it
would be bathed in uniform illumination
due to a shadow is judged to be much
more probable and so therefore when we
multiply all these things together this
hypothesis h1 comes out to be much more
probable optical illusions give us a
beautiful way of demonstrating this
hallucination Machinery of the brain we
call them illusions or optical illusions
but that's just in the laboratory we can
create these situations that fool you
but really this is something that's
happening all the time all of perception
is essentially a kind of illusion about
the world that the brain forms but a
mostly correct one for example consider
the scene here when what initially looks
at it when you just see a collection of
black and white sort of splotches in the
scene because you don't really
understand what's going on it's created
on purpose to be somewhat ambiguous but
with a little bit of hint look for a cow
immense amounts of detail begin to fill
in if you can't quite see it we'll
provide you some more detail
what's amazing about this process is
that beyond just recognizing the figure
in the scene or what the content it is
there's immense amounts of
three-dimensional detail and structure
that's being filled in the shape of the
cow's head the texture of the cow you
could separate the graininess as part of
the photographic process as opposed to
being part of the cow per se all of this
is being created by the brain
the initial ambiguity you had at the
beginning when you just saw it as a
bunch of black and white splotches and
boundaries in the scene that's just the
information being provided by the retina
that's just the data that's actually
being provided about the scene
everything else has to be filled in and
created by the brain
well wouldn't it be nice if we could
look inside the brain and see what's
happening when you see the cow in this
scene so here's one example of scene
we've created where we can actually do
that when one initially looks at this
scene one sees lines which appear to be
moving up and down but when we make a
manipulation of the scene we can see
that something else is going on it's
actually a diamond that's moving left
and right back and forth the reason why
we had an incorrect percept initially is
because the bars that were in front were
were hidden to be the same color as the
background so what's interesting about
this particular stimulus is that once
you know it's a diamond we can go back
to the case where the bars are hidden
and it turns out to be a bi-stable
percept meaning that in one case you see
it as a diamond moving left and right
and in another case you see this bars
moving up and down and it tends to flip
spontaneously on you about every 10
seconds or so so this makes an ideal
stimulus for a functional magnetic
resonance imaging experiment where we
can put the subject inside a scanner and
have them press one button when they see
the diamond and press another button
when they see it as lines moving up and
down when we look inside the brain what
we see is that initially when you see
this stimulus as a bunch of lines moving
up and down
there's initially a lot of activity in
the lower-level areas this activity
percolates up towards the higher-level
areas but there's not much activity
there and the higher
Aries because evidently there's not much
being made of this particular stimulus
but when the perceptive of a demon kicks
in when you finally see it as a whole
object moving back and forth you see a
lot of activity now in the higher level
areas and interestingly much less
activity in the lower level areas this
suggests potentially that the feedback
pathways are carrying the predictions of
these higher level areas to lower level
areas and that's essentially explaining
away the activity of their in their
explaining away all this ambiguity that
was potentially there before we're only
just still scratching the surface and
that you know the actual function of the
visual systems is something extremely
mysterious even something as simple as a
spider or a bee is something that you
just look at in awe and you're kind of
like even given all these mathematics
there's powerful mathematics and
computers and everything that we have or
still at a loss we're trying the best we
can but we need we need new tools we
need new theories and that's where the
Simon's Institute comes in like new
theories of computation it's gonna be
some smart kid you know 20 years from
now who has a new idea then they don't
they'll figure it out take us to the
next level
[Music]
you